oui c'était une grande firme de mesures
industrielles et de confection en
vêtements masculins de bordeaux mérignac
ainsi qu'un fabricant d'imperméables de
arctic ce nom que le comité des jeux
olympiques a confié la constitution du
vestiaire des athlètes qui se rendront à
mexico le mois prochain
si vous le voulez bien je vais vous
présenter les tenues qui constituent ce
vestiaire
d'abord la tenue voyage
celle ci comporte un polo blanc un
cardigan bleu ciel bord des bleu et
rouge un pantalon léger gris chaussures
noires imperméable blanc cassé la tenue
voyage est complétée d'une valise et
d'un sac de sport ensuite la tenue
défilé composé d'un blazer bleu france
agrémenté d'un blason bleu blanc rouge
frappé du coq gaulois d'un pantalon
blanc rayé noir une chemise bleu ciel
une cravate bleu foncé rayé rouge et
gris de mocassins beige clair cette
tenue sera complétée d'un chapeau panama
enfin une tenue de soirée composée d'un
costume bleu d'une chemise blanche et
d'une cravate très strict bleu foncé
avec une fine rayures blanches et vertes
de chaussures noires